welcome back everybody right before the
shutdown I was hanging with Beyonce
Drake Snoop Dogg Leo just to name a few
and that's just a normal day of the week
here in Las Vegas at Madame Tussauds I
went to visit their newest figures and
since then they've been quarantined just
like us waiting for this time to come
check it out
[Music]
Madame Tussauds Las Vegas is one of the
most iconic
instagram-worthy insane opportunities to
get photo ops
we offer interactive experiences all
throughout our attractions that let our
guests become part of the attraction at
every turn people have opportunities
with deejaying on the stage with Steve
Aoki riding on a wrecking ball swing
with Miley Cyrus getting on a
teeter-totter with Snoop Dogg and
indulging themselves in a 14-foot
oversized roulette wheel filled with
over a million poker chips and my
personal favorite is the hangover bar
experience it's a fully immersive
hangover bar which is designed after the
iconic movie our marvel experiences
which was great for families is a full
40 theater with sense effects movement
all that so when you're sitting in there
flying high with the superheroes you
actually feel like you're in the movie
because you have all kinds of effects
going on around you and then we also
have a virtual xscape room which is
great for families requires two people
to play you go in you have to solve all
the ignition models to escape to the
next level which is a time-traveling
journey to save the world
[Music]
our newest figure is queen bee Beyonce
herself we launched her back in November
she is an iconic figure and she was a
must-have in our attraction we also
launched the princess of R&B Aaliyah who
is dear to my heart from growing up with
her both of them have become fan
favorites across the art Instagram
channels and Facebook the creation of
these speakers goes all the way back to
Madame Tussauds self when she was
measuring celebrities creating death
masks back in the French Revolution so
we've carried those techniques through
each of these figures are a hundred
percent upon size so every measurement
we go through about 1500 measurements
where we're using the old tools and they
go through roughly 2000 photos and in a
sculpting process that we make sure the
color match tone everything is perfect
Madame Tussauds takes a lot of pride in
maintaining great relationships with the
talent these are iconic people that were
celebrating and we're trying to
immortalize them in time
so throughout even involving in the
launches so we look at creating a set we
really identify what is about that
person like the Kardashians known for a
labyrinth flower walls so we wanted to
make sure Khloe Kardashian's launch was
heartfelt so we actually launched her
own Khloe's birthday which got great
coverage she was adored it and loved the
background of the figure so we put a lot
of pride in making sure that we are
representing that person as to they are
their personality their talent it is
first and foremost the the biggest thing
Madame Tussauds focuses on we have a
great variety of packages it depends on
how immersed our guests would like to be
in the experience where they want to
celebrate themselves with the family and
kids and our Marvel 4d immersive
experience or if they would like to
purchase a drink package to go through
the hangover bar experience we do
recommend that our guests look online to
get their purchases you'll get a better
discount on alarm online and for our
local residents who we really truly
dearly love at if they come up to the
box office they present their local idea
they get 50% off admission to come in so
much fun as part of the reopen the
museum is also giving away free tickets
to our healthcare heroes and for more
information on their special offers and
of course their new safety protocols
visit Madame Tussauds comm / Las Vegas
Mercedes